Hello, in this final video, what we're going to do is create a second blueprint, this time for a button.
And this blueprint is going to be able to communicate with other instances of doors inside the world
to lock and unlock them. So it's a simple exercise to allow us to go over some of the basics of communicating between actors.
So what we're going to do is we're going to create a new blueprint entirely called the button.
So if you can right hand click, come up to blueprint class and select actor again.
And we'll call this BP underscore button. Now, if I double click and open up the button,
I'm going to place that across the top of the rest of them. For this, I'm going to need a couple of components.
First of all, what I'm going to need is a static mesh. I'm going to call this SM underscore button.
And in the static mesh, I'm going to search for corner. And you'll see that there is an SM corner, right?
It's going to bring up just this little static mesh that looks like that. That will work.
We just need a visual representation of the button at this point. And again,
the next thing that we're going to add is a box collision. Box collision, add that in.
And much like we did last time, I'm just going to move it in front and expand it a little bit so that we can overlap with it.
OK. That looks all right to me. Now we need to add code.
The code is going to be slightly similar to the code that we have for the door. Some of it is at least.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to jump into the door.
I'm going to search for the section that we had on enabling the input.
I'm going to drag over, press control C to put it into the clipboard.
Jump back to the button here and I'm going to press control V.
And that is all up and running. So I can select the the overlapping of the box.
I can also grab the E button because we're going to need that as well.
So we're already up and running with most of the code in this setup.
And I can check this works just by doing another print string. Just leave it saying hello for the time being.
I'm going to drag my button into the world. Rotate and drag up here.
Press play. Come over to the button. Press E and I can see that the hello is printing. Therefore, this is all up and running.
So let's get rid of the print string.
Now, the concept behind this button is that we can use it to lock or unlock one of the doors.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to come up to the variable. I'm going to add in a variable.
I'm going to call this variable door. And I'm going to flip on the eye to make it instance editable.
Now, this needs to be of a specific type. So I'm going to search.
You know how we search for actor and we were looking for references? This time, what I'm going to search for is the door.
So if I search for door, you can see that we have BP door and I can select that as a reference.
So this can be a reference for a door. Now, what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag in the door.
I want to do a couple of things. I'm going to jump back to the door itself and create a custom event.
Add custom event. You can see down here. And I'm going to call this toggle locked.
And on this event, I'm going to do a very simple. I'm going to do a couple of things.
The last thing I'm going to do is I'm going to get locked. I'm going to drag off and type in not.
And I'm going to search for not Boolean. That's under Boolean maths.
We talked about how the Boolean can be true or false. What not is going to do is it's going to invert it.
So if it's if locked is true, it will mean false will come out of there.
If locked is false, it will mean true. Now what I'm going to do, drag in and set locked.
So all this small script effectively does is it just inverts the value.
Now, the next thing I want to do is I want to change the color of the light.
Now, we've already made a function to do that, the change light color.
I'm going to drag that out and place that on there. Great.
So that's working. Now what I'm going to do is I'll go back to the button.
I'll drag off. I've saved and compiled the door.
I'm going to drag off here and I'm going to toggle locked and connect that up to E.
So we have two actors now. And when we press E on the button,
it is going to tell the door that it is connected to to fire the event toggled locked.
The toggle locked will invert the value of the locked Boolean and it will reset the colors.
Let's go back into the level. Now this button won't work until I set the door.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to set it to this door on the left here so we can easily see it.
I'm going to push play. Now, if I come up to this button and press E, you can see that it's flipping the toggle.
And while it's locked, I cannot open it. While it's unlocked, I can open it.
It's a really simple bit of functionality.
I can create multiple locks and connect them to multiple doors.
I can even make it so that we use an array for the locked. So I'll show you that.
At the moment, the door is set to be a single reference. However, under variable type,
I have a number of different options. If I select the array option,
let's change the variable and go away because it needs to figure out everywhere that the variable is referenced
to make sure it can see if it's invalidated any of the code. This might take a little amount of time.
Okay, so that's done. Now it's invalidated the code here. The thing about an array is we can have multiple
multiple doors in it. So I need to disconnect this
and might be able to plug this in directly.
See if that works. Yep, that just works. So you can either do a for loop
or in this instance, Unreal understands what to do. Now I can set
the door right here and it's going to toggle it on both the doors
at the same time or even more and just need to add an extra one to the array.
So that brings us to the end of this course. What we've done is we've
gone through the basics of programming by using blueprints. We've
created a couple of different actors. We've created functions to change the lights
and we played around with the variables and we dragged the instances into the world
to see that they can talk to each other and that we can interact with them.
Now this should be a good foundation for any future work you'd want
to do with blueprints. Thank you.